well they say that la attracts big fish
from little ponds who says that
who's this big fish from little ponds
right okay I mean I'm in town 45 years I
haven't haven't heard that but go on
maybe it's my own quote so okay all
right okay okay but that general sense
that a lot of people that come to LA or
maybe big shots back home in a town of a
thousand people and they come to this
town that's beautiful and challenging
and fast-paced and they're going up
against 20 versions of themselves
whether as a screenwriter an actor
filmmaker a dancer what do you say to
someone that maybe was used to getting
sort of more royal treatment back home
and then they come to LA and it's it's a
little more of a an eye opener you're
forced with the fact that you have to
wait in line for things maybe you're not
you don't have the same prestige as you
did in your small College back home why
you have to say anything or give advice
they will lose just something they're
going to learn by experience which is
really the only way to learn something
and keep it they're just gonna see that
that's the case you don't have to tell
them that I can see again there are
hostile people in the arts who would
like to put that person down you know
but I don't think discouraging people is
it's the way to go
and I would never reprimand any such
person they may be you know the best
writer that ever came out of Canton Ohio
but I you know you're here and there is
tremendous competition but you learn
about that and in the experience of
struggling with your art and you're
trying to do the best you can I would
still writers if your
lost and confused and disconnected and
frustrated and disappointed I'm glad to
hear it not because I'm a sadistic fiend
but to me it says you're having the
experiences that writers have yesterday
on the front page of the New York Times
Bigard about Philip Roth there's no more
successful writer than Roth
he's 79 and he's announcing that he
stopped writing at least stop running
fiction and I wrote down a quote this is
on the front page of yesterday Sunday's
New York Times he says writing is
frustration it's frustration
not to mention humiliation that's a
verbatim quote I realize I've actually
memorized it now this is Ross Roth has
had 31 books published 26 novels
published bunches of them have been made
into movies made a great deal of money
has a beautiful apartment on the Upper
West Side he has a gorgeous home in in
Connecticut in the countryside
um he's had as much success as any
writer has ever had and he finds it
frustrating and humiliating I mean
that's what art is it's a I've never
known any artist who was worth anything
who's really really satisfied with the
work that he did who felt comfortable no
Mel Brooks it's my privilege to know him
a little bit over the years he thinks
there's a party going on and he hasn't
been invited you know to this day Brooks
I mean it's a giant Titan in American
humor and comedy and film comedy
television comedy so um you know if
you're looking for comfort and to feel
good to feel reassured this is this is
the room let's place the look it never
changes my son is a he's 26
world's best son and like his
grandfather my father he's a musician
and he's launched a career he's trying
to break into scoring composing for
films and TV and video games and
advertisements and so on and he's just
having a sensational success you know
and I was he making a living he's making
such a living his mother and I had to
beat up on him here's a nice problem to
have with your kid to make sure that it
goes to the accountant our tax preparer
died also does his taxes make sure that
the estimated Quarterly's are filed on
time otherwise he's gonna have trouble
with the IRS now that's the kind of
front with your kid over your kid why am
i mentioning this because one thing he
doesn't seem to get yet is that it never
you know he he's working very hard he
has a lot a lot of work and I'm always
telling I'm a little too much work I
don't sound to better too much than too
little and things have a way of shaking
down and you know filling up the time
that that's for them if he had less work
he'd still use all of that time to do to
do the work but what he can only get
through experience isn't the
understanding that it's always
frustrating and and difficult it never
comes easy not for any practitioner I
have a lot of experience myself as a as
a writer I don't consider myself a
terribly important writer but I am a
much experienced writer and I've worked
in all the all of the media and I've
worked for all written feature-length
scripts for all of the studios the major
studios and many independent reduction
companies and a five books published
including best-selling nonfiction and
and fiction my last novel was a Times
bestseller for one week not a small
thing
[Music]
so for my own experience but not only my
own experiences my experience as an
educator allows me working very closely
with other artists on their own work I
kind of learned from their experience as
well and that's the way it is it's
always difficult it never gets easy
it's like losing weight people who have
weight issues often think if they could
just get that the 30 to 40 pounds off 45
55 pounds they need to lose if they
could just get that off then they could
stop obsessing about this and stop
worrying about this but doesn't work
that way if you want to keep the weight
off you guys worry about it every day
I'm I like to think that I'm fit why is
that because you know I never go on a
diet life is my diet every day I go to
the pool you know you sit you're on your
butt in your chair as a writer you know
you gotta get actors and dancers singers
understand the instrument the body is
your body is that's your instrument you
got to take care of writers don't
understand that as well sometimes you
gotta take care of yourself and you have
to stop looking for satisfaction and
[Music]
calm regarding you know your work I
never knew any writer who's really
really successful who wasn't unhappy
with the way stuff came out I just you
know Julius Epstein who wrote rest his
soul he's gone now but I met him a few
times he would griping about how they
ruined Casablanca he wanted it to be
this way and his brother had an idea for
this but oh no and that is well he's
just later talking about how to read
Casablanca it's not really that good he
doesn't think that's a blank if only
somebody would wreck my movie like they
wrecked Casablanca
Woody Allen I read an interview some
time ago Woody Allen and they said when
you look back at your last you know you
look back at your previous movies your
early movies and woody said stop okay so
what's the man I said I don't I don't
look back in my early movies I don't
look at any of my movies
they said well surely youth
you've pulled a Nihal off the shelf over
the last 40 years and taking a peek min
hat and seen at least somebody said no
not one frame why not he said because he
hates everything about them and now
Manhattan and Annie Hall are two of the
best movies ever made in my view and
here is the guy who wrote and directed
them wish you know he says all I see is
stuff I wish I had done differently I
never knew anybody gonna be a different
attitude about it by that you know
there's a very famous book missin it's
called adventures in the screen trade of
a William Goldman and Goldman usually
successful writer in its most famous
line the most famous line in the book is
nobody knows nothing because it really
is this is a business where the
exception is the rule and you just never
know how that's going to come out but
there's a much better line in that book
it seems to me that is overlooked by
most people he's at a meeting Sydney
and the late director is at the
meeting and he wants he Pollock wants to
do a script that bill is written and
they're talking to the money guy in a
restaurant and it's not going well then
I you can see it's not this guy's just
not interested in that film though you
know too risky to whatever you doesn't
want to do it and as it starts to get
worse and worse and this is as described
by Goldman Sydney Sydney says
wait a second I mean reaches for the
script and he and real Goldman
realizes oh my god oh no he's actually
gonna now read to the investor the
potential investor a passage from the
script and this horrifies Goldman and he
has the line that I'm focusing on which
is now you have to understand I hate
everything I've ever written that's
William Goldman he wrote Butch and
Sundance for God's sake
yeah hugely hugely successful writer
there can't be there are writers that
successful it's bill Goldman but none
more so and artists should not look back
at their at their work and if they do
they're gonna be disappointed in it I
have had a lot a lot of praise on some
of the things that I've done
certainly my last novel as I say was a
made the Times bestseller list and is in
action potential film rights sale right
now potentially happening and my
screenwriting book has been in imprint
for a you know quarter of a century and
one a lot a lot a lot of a lot of praise
when I pick up those books occasionally
and just open them up to the middle to
take a look around boy oh I see is
mistakes poorly stated notions clumsy
diction awkward phraseology you know
it's just constantly I'm just constantly
wincing and this is stuff that a lot of
people have you know Lance black I just
mentioned blurb that said it was really
really a very fun book to my
astonishment he clearly read it David
Kemp who was a hugely successful writer
in a alumnus who studied you
screenwriting at UCLA praised it to the
skies and many many other people but I
don't you know I can't I don't really
you know I can barely tolerate it and I
think that's common I think that's
pretty common among successful artists
and they should not look back but but
forward
you